peut très bien être optimiste avec toute
une foule dans mr deux mois mais que tu
mets de côté tu passe à autre chose
c'est tout con comme discours à mais en
ce moment vu que les cabinet de psy sont
remplies
vu qu'il ya plein de gens qui tombent
dans la déprime je trouve que ça fait du
bien que voilà et moi je veux être
l'image de ce à quoi qu'il en soit et
aient été ou cet été cet été mais on
devait faire des alors en forêt on
devait faire des galas mais il ya des
préfets qui nous annule parce que c'est
très compliqué faut des passes où on
peut pas mettre plus 5000 moi c'est
quand je suis un gars avec mes musiciens
on met dix mille personnes qui sautent
les uns contre les autres
donc on en fera quelques uns il ya la
pièce de théâtre aussi qui s'appelle
louis saez point fr et puis on attend le
mois d'octobre pour enfin faire cette
tournée des du plus grand cabaret du
monde s'est engagé ce faire le plus
possible quoi sinon je m'éclate et je
fais mon album off pour faire bosser mes
musiciens et pour rester dans la joie et
me faire plaisir je me disais tout à
l'heure tu es tellement loin de la télé
là maintenant à maintenant mais se sont
atténués derrière moi moi j'aime bien
venir si vous n'avez c'est loin loin
derrière moi j'ai à partir de là chez 67
piges
donc il me reste pas beaucoup mais c'est
une nouvelle ninja taklha mais une vraie
nouvelle vie avec d'autres valeurs avec
d'autres amis on a éloigné les [ __ ]
durant l'été une nouvelle vie avec des
amis les amis simple mais pas très bien
pourquoi c'est à dire ça et on en
parlait dans un deux minutes c'est que
tu vois quand j'ai vu jean dujardin je
te le jure j'ai vraiment je me suis dit
[ __ ] ça fait plaisir d'avoir encore
des mecs comme ça qui a un immense
succès et tu oublies pas de
reconnaissance
tu sais y'a un truc dans l'interview
dont vous lirez l'interview mais tout ce
qui m'a dit oui c'est les valeurs c'est
la famille c'est après son oscar
j'ai dit [ __ ] c'est une consécration
tu es tu dis non je travaille deux fois
plus a toujours autant d'amis qu'avant
quand et à la télé tous les samedis
soirs proches
non il y avait 60 époque non mais les
habite télé tu les a toujours tendance
et j'ai vu ce phrase ya pas il ya des
aphorismes justement le tue quelqu'un
qui n'est plus ton ami sap a été ton ami
tout simplement non des amis ouais je
reste là mais j'ai des amis dans plein
de
différent pas forcément des gens qui
vont au camping mais j'en ai aussi mais
on téléthon droit commun au téléthon à
howie mais j'ai toujours aidé mais que
j'aime bien il ya eu bigot que jericho a
quitté tu vois les pires einstein et
puis jean brosset bacteria les mêmes
codes germanium
mais la télé moi je crache pas dessus
moi j'en ai beaucoup netflix mais il ya
des choses à des clashs dessus pour les
suivre il ya des choses que j'aime que
j'aime énormément puis ça fait partie ça
aussi ça fait partie de la détente
je crois qu'il faut tout ce qui se passe
dans l'actualité
je regardais sur la jfpi appli mâcon il
faut pas dramatiser mais faut pas non
plus banalisée il ya un moment où fo
faut poser je crois que tout ce que je
sens tu sais que je sens assez bien les
gens tout ce que je sens autour de moi
ils ont envie que ça ce point ouais
ouais c'est vrai et ils ont envie de
cette bienveillance la de ce2 c'est vrai
c'est bien beau chaque région afrique
c'est vrai il ya eu des rumeurs comme
quoi tu as dit n'est que le président
non mais c'est jouer au baby foot avec
de gaulle à travers et va très bien de
gaulle non email m'emmerde tous à venir
mais c'est qu'il est venu il est venu
dans mon village à martel de marc
atallah
j'étais pas avec lui à martel d'accord
non c'est pas tant que président des
choses que tout bon dimanche et m6 et
bastien mais on continue à se parler pas
vrai
bon c'est vrai on aurait parlé de quoi
enfin voyons
on